l'energia di noi non siamo
non si crea e non si distrugge
sofficemente si trasforma ogni cosa
energia anche la massa come ci ha
insegnato einstein tutto scorre
l'energia non fa eccezione allora il
segreto dell energia sta che come
imbottigliarla farle scorta usata come
riguardo vogliamo come si fa un buon
vino
abbiamo imparato a gestire varie forme
di energia partire dal suo 400.000 anni
scor
la legna era un punto ora un importante
serbatoio di energia rilasciarli
accomando sotto forma di calore e mezzo
nella con video un calore certo bagnato
lungo la storia fino ad oggi non
ritroviamo nel camino di casa un
motorino le nostre auto nella centrale
elenca dappertutto insomma ma lo sapete
che la maggior parte di calore viene
perso assieme ai fumi di combustione
peraltro quasi sempre nocivi
infatti che a noi veniamo la legna
notizia in casa e poi e gettiamo via i
funghi crescita a convertire in energia
utile per i nostri scopi solamente una
piccola parte lesa lo rigenera
questa inizia in ribasso e vicenda
ancor peggio la materia prima il
serbatoio di energia dietro a quel
calore cambiato nel corso della storia
in particolar modo con le rivoluzioni
industriali
siamo passati dalla legna per lo meno
rinnovabile le fonti fossili non
rinnovabili
malcanton quel petrolio e di gas
naturale
negli ultimi 50 anni abbiamo il tratto
da quasi tutti 20 volte la quantità di
energia mai usata dall intera umanità
avanti re della pressione ed è tuttora
rappresentano in modo gestiamo la quasi
totalità della nostra energia
sono serbatoi piccoli molti casi sono
comodi sono semplici sono pratici da
usare a nostro comando di giorni di
notte con il bund con il cattivo tempo
funzionano sempre partono ciarlo
vedete strategia sta nei comuni pigliare
noi usiamo le fonti fossili per ogni
cosa per varano la nostra vita
il trasporto quando accendiamo la luce
di casa non abbiamo una lama chigi
quando va a fare la spesa
permettergli per lavarci forma già
perché gli faccio i petrolchimici come
la plastica può dare
noi tutti sappiamo nel caso significa
inquinamento
cambiamento fu marco siccità non c'è più
neve sulle nostre alpi non c'è quasi più
acqua nei nostri fiumi
guerra
povertà
malattia
tutto legato
tutto questo è il risultato di un
modello economico ed energetico sta
mente lineare costruiti co.ind e getta
basato su tre imperativi
usa o punta come quando facciamo
qualcosa se cicli naturali non consento
di rigenerare tutti gli elementi alla
base di queste fasi allora questo
modello non è sostenibile
finalmente stiamo saranno delle
circolari che introducono altri tre
imperativi riuso recupero e riciclo il
termine tale non deve più ed il 3 ma non
vado finché un modello energetico sia
realmente sostenibile corano due
ingredienti da un lato la lotta agli
sprechi e l'hard iniziale della domanda
di energia a quanto strettamente
necessario
dall'altro la risposta ovvero in modo in
cui pronunciamo e gestiamo energia deve
essere sinceramente sostenibile e
circolari che ognuno di noi a
disposizione il sole un argento i mari
fiumi calore della terra energia che ci
è offerta dalla natura secondo i propri
siti
abbiamo imparato a generare l'energia
elettrica pulita questo può anche
rinnovata ma ne produzione in costante
imprendibile che la natura non è al
comando se infatti non consumiamo
l'energia nel tardo stesso che viene
prodotta la fregata
creando una simmetria val certa è la
domanda nigeria
risolvere questo problema necessario
ricordare che il segreto dell'energia
sta nei commenti dal
minimo che riteniamo che questa energia
batterie
noi in bottiglia energia che ci serve in
accumulatori laggiù elettrochimici
giocavate il magazine a rilasciare un
energia elettrica ha colmato
la tecnologia delle celle di livio dopo
40 anni di evoluzione è oggi il
principale veicolo che rende possibile
la rivoluzione elettrica siamo vivi sono
consigliate aspetta quindi risolto
allora come mai consumo di mostri di
fossi e l'inquinamento sono in costante
crescita mentre l'utilizzo di fonti
rinnovabili
e ancora relegato ad una minoranza
dotati di più la verità se ci sono
ancora molte limitazioni anche per le
batterie al litio ad ogni purtroppo il
loro ciclo di vita
in quasi lineare ma il caso e le
immagini si sta prendendo si sono
proprio questi tipi di batterie loro
punizione utilizzo smaltimento
riduzione crea problemi dentali sociali
politici economici perché
anzitutto sono costituite da natali
prime rare non rileva come litio cobalto
nichel manganese la cui estrazione
mineraria consuma enormi risorse
energetiche e inca pensate che per
registrare il litio parliamo del sole
minuto livio necessario per costruire
l'abbazia di una auto elettrica
è necessario quindi equivalente d'acqua
di una piscina
a che verrà peraltro pronta minata
quello che succede ad esempio nei limiti
stabiliti o sudamerica dove gli attori
villaggi sono privati dell'acqua da bere
a questo motivo il congo d'altra parte è
il maggior esportatore al mondo di
covato per questo ne aumenta
l'instabilità geopolitica sotto il
controllo di monopoli commerciali chi si
attendano peraltro a tutti note a fare
finora l'intera filiera produttiva di
batteria in piega enormi risorse e
inquina
inquina come ad esempio gli ac
infine se ma per io sono difficilmente
riciclabili e riutilizzati
pensate che ad oggi sono 5 su 100 in una
riciclata se utilizzare se non ha detto
la pace dei popoli
anche riuso ha una bassissima resa
perché le batterie elettrochimica
aspettavano in media vivendo lo vediamo
cellulare dopo qualche ha
inoltre batteria al litio consentono
anche modelli pratici tempo ucina
d'operatività sono gustose fino al mar
su una decina diano non sono tappe gli
studenti di potenza delle fonti
rinnovabili offrono di caricamento
mentre avremmo bisogno di ricarica
veloci prinoc bejing le rocce o presepe
infimo la sicurezza come diciamo
che insomma quel pericolo di spostare
gran parte dei problemi comuni
lontano dai nostri occhi senza realmente
risolta intanto abbiamo le discariche di
proferire
ancora una volta il segnato dell'energia
sta nel coi modi a
lavorare francamente al miglioramento
non lo gira al litio in batteria
elettrochimica che in generale ne sono
un esempio il batteria flusso che
offrono una vita operativa di oltre 20
anni fa la ri scalabilità grazie
all'utilizzo di elettroni di liquidi
anziché soling che vengono fatti reagire
tramite siti né cancro
anche queste batterie tuttavia
coinvolgono processi e sostanze chimiche
inquinanti come in val avio
se dunque è il nostro osservatore ed
energia non è sostenibile
non lo è l'intera filiera energetica ci
vada spesso
quali sono dunque le alternative a matri
elettrochimica come possiamo veramente
me lanciarci della sostenibilità
beh in questo momento non ci sono
soluzioni praticabili affidamento su
larga scala ma ci sono prospettive
idrogeno
nell'emilia combustibile bruciato
produce solamente acqua in aggiunta al
calore e l'energia ed i capanni di rose
denso fenomeni in giro
pensate lo space shuttle di fatto
alimentato con idrogeno e ossigeno
tuttavia nonostante i continui progressi
in meta sostenibile l'idrogeno non è
complessa energivora se socia 15 mesi
alessandrino
nonna anch'esso stoccaggio e complesso
occorrono salvatori speciale in funzione
come questo ma molto più gravi e in
molto più registra servono
infrastrutture da vestirà macchine
speciali per poterlo usare
inoltre pericoloso da maneggiare in ogni
sua fase
sicuramente il segreto di energia stare
comode chiamo mistri dell'altro bolani
ad esempio come trova significa
solamente più grandi più veloci per
immagazzinare un modo che energia ad
alta potenza
poi abbiamo il super quindi sopra
elettrici oggi sulla questa che
magazzino ma certamente energia
elettrica come comuni fila
poi abbiamo la comuna grande azionale
magazine a energia sollevando una massa
la recupera lasciandola cadere
primo gelato lo più di grande con delle
crew sollevano dei blocchi di cemento
centinaia di metri d'altezza
infine sono i sistemi ta che
immagazzinano energia in un liquido non
è scaldato e con sabato come nessun
importo dell'acqua calda di nuovo più in
grande come l'inter nè quelle nave
come dici questo sistemi possono essere
due patenti proprio sacconi gli spetta
ad atti realvideo con quindi di più
facile associazione con i marchi
rinnovabili con due però si è
inizialmente più grande e più pesanti
più costosi varietà di autonomia e
proprio per questo motivo c'è una
batteria al litio vede nostro lari
noi crediamo la ricerca si fa
concentrarsi per sviluppare anche un
presto un alternativa una tecnologia
competitiva sotto tutti i punti di vista
e tra litio che in aggiunta sia
completamente sostenibile circolare è
costituita da materie prime naturali
gestita in maniera responsabile
disponibili o comunque nel modo basso
costo
il cavallo il più possibile nascar per
minimizzare gli sprechi
trasformate grazie a tecniche
all'avanguardia
consapevoli dice dare un nuovo volto
ecologico alle parte del futuro dove ci
lavora a km zero senza rischi grazie a
strumenti semplici alla portata di tutti
questo caso e prodotti completamente
circolari fine rino questa la batteria
su cui io e pari stiamo lavorando per
recuperare l'equilibrio perduto a
partire dalle nostre tasse e impostarsi
senza lasciare solchi indelebili al
nostro passaggio perché vogliamo un
futuro migliore sostenibile per il
pianeta dalle persone
la responsabilità è nostra il momento
giusto
e adesso
dell'energia sta nel come figlia ma
questo solamente uno dei tasselli
infossare per comporre inferta quella
domanda energetica domanda che però è in
frontino metto
sfatto e noi siamo sempre di più
dobbiamo sempre rischi in caso più
grandi auto più veloci tecnologie più
alla moda alziamo a riscaldamento
incondizionato arte non tappa in questo
distacco ci starebbe noce
ma io allora vi chiedo quante di queste
esigenze sono davvero così fondamentali
per noi
ci accontentassimo un po di più e
sforzassimo un po di più non sono
bianchi facile superiore alla domanda
energetica
lei is more dicono genesi suoi averi di
meno validi più e forse saremo anche più
felici